sirens rang out as war cyl commemorated
the jewish men and women who rose up
against the nazi 70 years ago an
uprising that cost thousands of lives
simcha Rotem is among Friday's guests of
honor the 89 year old is one of the few
still alive today who fought in the
uprising sure dish mover garage we
wanted to choose the way we would die
but to this very day the thought
torments me that we were too quick to
decide whether somebody had days or
weeks to live only to then die in the
uprising on april nineteen nineteen
forty three SS troops entered the warsaw
ghetto rounding up sixty thousand jews
for deportation to the Treblinka
extermination camp but they were met
with resistance that lasted for nearly a
month in the end the uprising was
crushed as the germans began burning
down buildings the polish president
brawny suave Komarovsky said that no
other european capital had suffered as
badly during the war and under Hitler's
Germany as Warsaw did he said both left
behind a trail of destruction today only
three of the resistance fighters are
still alive the others were killed in
the uprising or in the death camps